let's jump into audience questions for
the week first question hey David why
doesn't the press just call out saris a
Huckabee Sanders on her lies in press
conferences is it because they're afraid
they will ban the press from press
conferences you basically mostly
answered the question I've suggested
many times that listen Sarah Huckabee
Sanders doesn't answer questions she
last week was asked what my Donald Trump
thought about something Michael Cohen
did and she said she doesn't represent
or speak for Michael Cohen so she can't
answer when of course the question was
well what does Donald Trump think you do
speak for Trump right that is your job
as press secretary and she was allowed
to just move on to another one so
there's a couple different reasons there
number one is yes there's no question
that this is a white house that is very
very punitive and if you start to become
a problem more than just the level of
being argumentative that they sort of
expect and are willing to tolerate like
if you become so obstinate that you will
repeat the same question the last person
asked until it's answered you do lose
lose risk losing access and this also
relates to why sometimes on corporate
media you will not get the
confrontations that you sometimes see in
other countries where it's expected that
news reporters and journalists are going
to be tougher on elected officials
because here they're afraid of losing
access and that was part of why you know
as Genki ogor told us when he decided to
leave MSNBC he believed he was being
told you've got to be less hard on the
obama administration because partially
they don't want to lose access right
they want to be able to keep
interviewing those people so I think
that that is a big big part of it
especially when you deal with the White
House press corps too because it seems
like there are two layers of access yeah
one is getting in the room the other one
is getting called on and you know
usually the legacy outlets like CNN the
AP they'll always get their questions
right answered but some of the more
fringe ones they're trying to you know
be part of like the upcoming news media
they're mostly not they may not get
called on yeah so I think that the fear
of losing access is part of it there is
another thing which is remember under
Sean Spicer when at a certain point it
just got really bad like maybe it was
during the height of his laughably
comical lies there was a point where he
started doing off-camera audio only
press briefings in his office with just
hand
picked people and not even everybody in
the press corps was told about it they
also might end up not just personally
losing access but almost making it so
that they're destroying the concept of
the White House press briefing and
instead Sarah Huckabee Sanders will hand
pick some people and just brief them in
our office which is a form of losing
access but it's actually even worse it's
not only that you lose access it's that
they stop even communicating as if it
were even transparently but at least in
front of a camera so I have many times
said if everybody does it and then they
just stop doing briefings it will be a
real problem for them and you will have
free speech concerned individuals even
those on the right say this isn't right
if it's just some outlets that choose to
do this you risk just getting kicked out
and then the press briefings continue
just with the friendly faces if you
think they have been that punitive it
does seem like they're calling on Fox
News and I don't know who else Breitbart
maybe a little bit more than legacy
outlets sure but you know Jim Acosta
he has been misbehaving throughout this
entire presidency and he's still in that
room I think the reason that we've not
seen them be as punitive of the
challenging questions as maybe they
would be expected to be is that because
Trump has developed the fake news
narrative it plays into them being able
to say Jim Acosta in the press briefing
room in the fake news ba-ba-ba-ba-ba
they're able to use it slightly to their
advantage if it changes into simply
repeating the question because it's not
getting answered that's harder to just
say it's all fake news when people are
just saying hey listen you're not
answering the question